a spacesuit has to do three things it
has to maintain pressure so your blood
doesn't start boiling in the vacuum of
space
it has to provide oxygen so you can
breathe and it has to protect against
the environment
extreme heat extreme cold and direct
sunlight
this won't do any of those it's just a
replica of that one that's the actual
soccer spacesuit that tim peake the most
recent british astronaut used in space
the folks here at the national space
center wouldn't let me try on a real one
which
is fair enough versions of that suit
have been protecting astronauts since
the 1970s and there are variants still
used today
it's not designed for hours-long
spacewalks it's basically an emergency
personal
lifeboat for if the ship you're
traveling on uh springs a leak
and it provides those three things
pressure oxygen
environmental protection now a couple of
months ago i had a video where an ai
tried to suggest stories and titles that
i could cover and one of the things it
came up with was the long forgotten
history of the british moon landings
not strictly true of course we never
actually got there but
one of the team here got in touch and it
turns out that in the 1940s
15 years before kennedy said that
america chose to go to the moon
the british interplanetary society did
have
similar plans including our own space
suit
the bis was set up in 1933 by a man
called phil cleta and
he had this plan he wanted to get
together with like-minded individuals
who are interested in space flight and
what the possible future of space flight
might be
rocket technology was suddenly moving
forward in a way that
actually space flight was something
tangible and
might well be realistic the bis weren't
seriously expecting to launch a mission
to the moon on their own
but they did want to say hey we think
this is possible
and we think britain should do it and
one of the number illustrator ralph
smith
drew up plans for a space suit so we
have an exhibition here at the national
space center that focuses on the space
race and people tend to think about
america and the soviet union and we
wanted to tell something of what
britain was up to at the same time as we
were planning for our exhibition we were
leafing through a research document and
looking at the history of the bis
and immediately this picture jumped out
of somebody wearing this incredible
looking
spacesuit that they've designed and
immediately we just said
we have to make this it looks wonderful
but no one ever built it
until a few years ago so i get a call
and where do you start you've got two
drawings basically rather than just say
well i'll make a replica a facsimile of
it
i thought let's look at the materials
that were available at the time
cotton and rubber much like a modern
spacesuit is made
out of beta fabric and a rubber pressure
layer inside
and the pressure's inside it it can't
expand out any further it can't balloon
out he would have an oxygen supply in
his backpack there
so he's being fed this oxygen supply
going through past his face
down through the suit and recycling back
into the backpack again for expulsion
in the way just like an apollo suit did
here you've got what we call the
convolutes and there to give a bit of
movement
at the arm and right up here you've got
cloth of silver
if he's getting cold on the surface of
the moon
he can then pull this cape around him
and now any heat that's radiating out
from the suit
he can then trap that heat in and it
reflects the heat back into the body
again
so these little pins here they are in
fact little standoff
mushrooms so when the cape is hanging
over them there's a gap between the
surface of the suit and the surfaces of
the cape
and that gap of vacuum means there's no
physical
thermal transfer from the suit out into
the vacuum of space
you'll have noticed that on the front of
his chest he's got this rather strange
device here this is an
airlock imagine the circumstances you're
on the surface of the moon you find an
interesting rock
you open the airlock you put the rock
into the airlock you close the airlock
now you withdraw your arms inside the
suit through these
exceptionally large holes here and using
that long
front you can examine that rock that
you've just taken off the lunar surface
but you'll also notice there is a
shooting stick and it gives you a
walking stick comes seat
you get tired on the surface of the moon
you open the seat part of the shooting
stick
and you sit down they've kind of thought
of everything really
so how do you build something like this
and stay to those 1940s techniques
we turned to what would have been
available at the time
even to this silver finish here on the
helmet
and in fact the people we went to to get
this vacuum plating done they were an
original company that would have been
doing the original
if it had ever happened and in fact when
we took the helmet into them they said
oh well we finally got to do it then
there's newsreel footage from the 1940s
which says the bis estimated half a
million pounds
to send someone to the moon in today's
money that's about 20 million
the apollo program roughly cost the us
government 10 000
times that it's safe to say that the
bis's plans were
optimistic so how well would the british
spacesuit have held up against an actual
trip to the moon
we're pretty sure this would be the mark
one if this had
ever really walked on the moon this
would have been the mark 8 the mark 9.
remember on the moon you only have to
pressurize up
if you're breathing pure oxygen to about
four and a half pounds per square inch
this easily would have been capable of
taking that pressure
but it just would have been pretty
immobile you simply can't lift your arms
up very high because
of the nature of this deep shoulder
means that the arm just can't
rise up i think the bis were very
serious about going to the moon
they had nowhere near as much
information as
nasa would have had in the 1950s and 60s
about the realities of
space flight and particularly the
challenges of getting to the moon
but certainly these weren't crazy people
just throwing around
ideas there was lots of really talented
people they were just nowhere near as
complex in terms of the materials that
they had
but they weren't available to them at
the time so who knows had they have had
the
the time and the money to develop the
sort of space age materials that went
into some of those later suits
more time to practice and actually do
some practical experiments then who
knows
quite possibly thank you so much to
everyone at the national space center
along with the space suits they've got
rockets and satellites and an actual
piece of the moon
you can find out more about them at the
link in the description
i mean it's probably a good thing the
real ones are made to measure because um